alors lucien peut on nous jette donc né
le 18 mars 1948 mort le 24 juin 1962
niveau fantôme novices ou il est donc
sur le point de passer votre diplôme d'
esprit frappeur et d'accéder au rang d'
le fantôme standard ça alors êtes vous
prêt à passer cet examen
whissell alors vous allez donc chasser
hors de l'hôtel votre premier client
suit la chambre 407
alors quel sera votre technique chez moi
je te conseille de livrer ses
chaussettes et les vivants ils viennent
pas tant leur donnent leurs chaussettes
mans hermès qu'est ce que tu fous là
magie donne des conseils quoi pour pas
qu'ils se voir la classe 3 franche comté
un rôle ou là mais non mais je peux te
guider le petit chien fantôme de niveau
4 avec ça on sait que les fantômes de
merde
non c'est tout rond et ça existe ernest
au jeu te rappelles tu as raté trois
fois de ton examen
un vol a été tranchée qu'on l'a inventée
pour toi seront toque de merde souviens
tu essaies marc chikli comme à 8h ans
trois fois
sinon moi je te dis tu les voltigeuses
montbardois ernest j'ai un examen passé
là tu fais chier
bon lucien rachat c'est votre premier
client de l'hôtel rym siècle bonjour
bonjour madame normalement j'ai une
chambre au nom de ménard vous êtes dans
la 403 et l'asie bonjour j'aimerais y
revient bonjour alors j'aimerais une
chambre et la 403 s'il vous plaît vous
voyez là oui j'aimerais une chambre près
de 400 exigeant oui je suis vite et
j'aimerais une chambrée de la 403 et
vous voyez oui je hais je comprends pas
ils savent quoi la voilà qu'est ce que
je peux faire pour vous j'aimerais une
chambre et à 403,7 compliqué j'ai pas de
championnat 4 ans 3,6 à la casse en
équilibre ah voilà je prends de sa part
la cadence à toujours prendre un carton
mais je ne vous dire que j'avais pas de
la 470 oui à régler un petit hôtel
d'accord et c'est combien c'est ultra
cher d'accord j'ai vraiment reçu
avec là que tu fais à montreux tu fais
montreux choisi comme on veut au choix
vous estival série montre que tu fais ce
que tu veux en suisse bah écoute j'ai
posé la même question que tu fais là
c'est trop bizarre de voir la wave je
suis là pour le festival de montreux
comedy festival est ce que tu as vu sur
facebook que j'allais au festival et tu
m'a suivi c'est que je commence à en
avoir marre de tes combine de merde tu
peux pas faire comme two way avec lara
war pression là et c'est coincidence
c'est tout tu pas accepter bonne foi que
l'europe a choisi contre l'islam
c'est dans les motels maïs félix
augustin travail stable à lui c'est
félix graphique c'est pas ton et font un
peu chelou salut mec est donc ça va
mieux mais oui ça va pour que tu poses
la question
j'ai eu très actif en ce moment je fais
de la muscu je prends soin de moi je lui
parle de livres jeux mais du coup vu
qu'on est tous au festival comme ça pour
faire un truc tous ensemble genre un
spectacle je sais pas je sais pas encore
mais moi ça va être short niveau
derrière ce qui ramène une paroisse mais
on peut se faire un des genres demain
m'arrêter là haut nous miserons lula
aussi et qui tu parles pas eu là on peut
parler conquis monsieur je peux parler
tranquille quoi à qui à quoi un de quoi
tu parles
ni condé qui tu parles eux mais qui eux
nous bon faut que j'aille chercher un
christ alix on se voit vite un nom mais
que vous êtes sérieux la très sérieux
ont fait pas ça aux gens assez bien
cette phrase aussi commenté gravité nous
ont faits pour fait pas ça aux gens
laissez moi tranquille sa fabrique que
ça c'est bien aussi
les hémois [ __ ] qu'est tenez vous
prêts il a non mais sérieux c'est quoi
ce pays
on est où là ok donc vous avez tous
décidé de me faire chier dans cet hôtel
c'est ça ok on y va donc 3 2
le mec fille les galères n'esquissait de
faire peur à la meuf du quatrième venez
vite un nom mais il est nul et nul on va
arrêter d'en faire tout un échec mais
rien poil à l'ego bon il est où le mec
le droit en laqué - pas le rouge et or
là il est proche du clan des bons ce que
vous allez faire allait lui donner ce
chagrin non non non non attendez
attendez
déjà je peux pas lui donner parce que je
suis bête noire c'est ça oui voilà du
coup j'ai peut-être un petit service à
vous demander quoi vous avez remarqué
que l'hôtel était plein de fantômes du
spectre dont je suis le coordinateur
ce que je vous demande c'est de rentrer
dans votre chambre vous attendez
sagement ernest qui est un fantôme
on pourrait qualifier de nul nul à chier
il fait peur à personne
vous faites semblant d'avoir peur vous
flippez votre votre
race et vous vous déguerpissez quoi donc
si j'ai bien compris ce que voulait que
je fasse c'est prendre une chance pour
la nuit ouais ne pas dormir dedans et en
plus faut que la paye cette chambre que
ça non c'est pour ça je peux m'arranger
pour qu'elle soit payée pardon oui
donc en gros joujou une formule gratuite
quoi breil et services vod et avec avec
les chaînes à 58 les chaînes pour nous à
vous partez monsieur
l'enjeu non je reste je vous avais pris
là je me suis fait un gros porc et
analyser la victime
ok un mec pas très costaud marche kevin
qui fascine et m2 premiers frissons à la
bleue et c'est bien ça je me faire un
coup de pub
de faire le but et a écrit bleu et jaune
abus sais pas je m'étais dit ça serait
des mecs qui nous voit c'est ça oui non
mais c'est pas ça c'est que je peux pas
écrire but mais sur la buée honte et ça
me la fait pas à écrire buée sur l'abus
et en espérant faire peur pouvoir tu
dois écrire un truc genre derrière toi
ou je te vois tu vois je te vois je te
vois sèchement bien son jeu trop cher je
te vois avec as pas avec un x j'ai pas
la faute était depuis ancré pas bon
comme ça écrit john rambo ii ça va pas
bien sûr c'est qu'à des voix lasse
effacement bien s'achever cet été dans
une autre chambre là mais je vous vois
je le mets qui peut vous voir si ça
marche et ça a marché
il a crié tout a tant réussi à chasser
un client de l'hôtel non il est juste
crié mais moi j'ai jamais fait clé
quelqu'un avant visite de moi d'autres
trucs à vous faire peur à quelqu'un
d'autre dans sérieuse attends je sais à
qui on pourrait faire peur bon en gros
depuis psychose nous ce qui nous fait
peur tu vois c'est les douches n'hésite
pas tu le malmène tu vois même s'il
touche au kiki je pense que ça risque
que tu dois prendre
alors ça va tu as touché sa [ __ ] un peu
resté bas rend donc maintenant ce que tu
peux lui faire ces genres un petit rire
d'enfant genre bien critique non à rire
de clown plus à rire de claude c'est
bien ça ça fait peur ça du tout ouais
depuis ça on a tous peur du tout tous pu
croire ça tu te mets derrière lui tu vas
pression aurait comme ça et tu fais un
petit rire comme ça tu fais ça va
j'essaie c'est de la merde du coup toute
fausse - faire c'est que tu as parlé à
l'envers ouais d'accord genre du latin
j'ai pas réussi j'ai toussé ou je sais
ce que tu peux faire pour pas un truc
trop hardcore écoute pour faire peur des
fois il faut faire des trucs hardcore
butt pardon que si vous faites ça on
fait de caméra cachée là pour pour
internet ou internet ou les jeunes vous
êtes vraiment du gros con hockey et il
va comme un bourrin et une main de
maître ce connard conjointement la
société je me suis dit ils vont avoir
besoin d'éléments forts et je me suis
dit que gauthier nous pour l'ept métier
il a vu que le verra je disais quoi
ouais quand il est rentré en société
qu'est ce que c'est que ça lasse et je
t'emmerde tout
c'est pour moi non c'est pas moi je ne
sais pas moi je reviens c'est pas moi ok
maintenant qu'est leur jeu on passe à
l'étape 2 du plan robot oui en gros ce
que tu vas faire
ah oui pas c'est moi le conseil des
fantômes
ouais qu'est ce qui se passe car à jeter
entendu crier chute à porter a été
complètement ouverte dieu
t'inquiète pas tu es mons
arrête des tourments et l'esclave est
calme tarage orientera vers une activité
un peu plus constructive
merci que nature a peur maintenant
sort
il commence à fait ça normalement ça
devrait plus arriver mais si ça arrive
tu m'appelles je dois chan 4 ans et
ouais ça te dirait qu'on mange ensemble
ce soir ça j'ai pas mal de chose à faire
j'ai l'entraînement de psychique la
muscu un peu à faire mais j'ai trouvé un
petit créneau pour toi on avait
peut-être
alors ça marche et ce soir avant nous et
ce soir tu pourras mais des fois on fait
un petit truc bien sympa tous les deux
ouais non non en fait me dis ça vu que
je me sens prêt repasser le diplôme je
voulais m'entraîner
ce soir sur des vrais clients mais non
mais ce taux plein de classe tout cas se
plaignent tout à la fois juge comprend
bien tout tout tout tout un foie gras
d'oie est - ce soir on va envoyer du
méga pas t&d koala et les stocks ne sais
pas où je pourrais trouver du méga ses
conseils il se mettre au foot on passe
dans des plans d'eau
c'est vrai je ne lâche pas mal de clubs
on sent qu'ils sont ok c'est chouette et
c'est quelque chose qu'il faut chasser
oui très bien
l'a45 de 407 mais non même si la chambre
de félix at-on à will you mr barbez
c'est comme ça non mais je peux pas
chasser félix qui peut nous voir oui
mais bon étant donné la difficulté des
missions ils ont dit que tu pourrais
éventuellement directement accéder au
rang de fantômes de style quoi papa
fantôme standard directement fantôme de
style fantôme de style direct
non non on va faire ça écoute ernest
depuis la nuit des temps les morts font
peur aux vivants lui il est vivant alors
il peut nous voir de moi de voir tout un
bon ça reste un avion tu fais peur
voilà la mission fantôme de ce type
alors monsieur un peu mon ami maintenant
makoun c'est lui ou c'est nous
du coup depuis que je suis dans cet
hôtel j'ai des dons d'un télékinésie
d'hydrothérapie d'hydrothérapie hoeber
que plus de 20
waouh et encore tu as rien vu incroyable
écoute je vais aller faire pipi
mais toi ne bouge surtout pas
écoute je sais que tu en rendez vous
mais je tenais à m'excuser pour la
dernière fois je sais pas ce qui m'est
arrivé je n'étais pas moi je pense
sincèrement que que l'hôtel est lente et
non t'inquiète pas c'est encore un coup
de fil x commencé encore un bout de
phoenix
félix il a toujours été comme ça je ne
sais pas quand on est fait c'est
vraiment convaincant mais il fait ce
genre de truc quand on était ensemble on
voyait pas pendant des semaines se
laisser pousser la barbe
il revenait il me faisait croire qu'il
n'est de futur et qu'il fallait que je
couche davantage avec lui parce que
sinon notre famille allait être en
danger
mais vous êtes toujours ensemble non
parce que moi je veux pas mettre en
travers de quoi que ce soit si une
relation non non non non non tu
demanderas rien du tout si j'aime moi
j'aime bien passer du temps avec toi et
moi j'aime bien quand c'est pour ça
aussi je t'aime bien en soit demain
ouattara est ce que tu vas me voir voler
j'ai un truc à te dire en fait le
conseil a accepté que je repasse mon
examen sérieux c'est cool ça c'est bien
ouais c'est cool sauf que c'est toi je
dois choisir à c'est moins bien armé du
coup tu vas pas accepter ça va faire je
me disais peut-être qu'on pourrait faire
semblant quoi genre sais pas je rentre
dans ta chambre tu te met à crier et tu
quittes l'hôtel ouais nan c'est pas mal
mais non mais c'est mort parce que je
viens ici non ouais non mais je sais
mais mes fâche pas tu peux faire ça pour
moi juste un service indien
non mais je sais je sais franchement et
merci sérieux c'était trop cool tueur
mais clara et moi tu vois on se retrouve
enfin oui mais écoute club veut pas de
toi à mes d'accord aux aidants tu dis ça
en fait tu dis ça pour le vénère et du
coup je me barre de l'hôtel d'accord
tout prix avait nommé tournait pas à
faire des petits stratagèmes pour
arriver à ses fins comme toi je te dis
la vérité maintenant tu dis ça à tu dis
ça parce que tu es jaloux tu dis ça
parce que tu es jeune homme jaloux de
quoi t'as rien tu t'es jaloux parce que
parce que moi je suis vivant je peux
encore baiser et toi tu as le sommes
parce que tu es mort et du coup tu peux
plus baiser voilà c'est n'importe quoi
de toute façon c'est jamais baisé
humaines de mon vivant
mais tu vois ça m'étonne pas par exemple
ah ouais bah tu sais quoi je vais le
passer l'examen et prépare toi à bien
chier dans ton froc
ouais d'accord ok ben vas-y essaye de me
faire peur et c'est un peu de me faire
peur est de fantômes de merde c'est ça
crève
non non on crève pas tiens d'ailleurs
reste bien vivant comme ça on se
croisera plus jamais j'espère qu'il va
avoir une belle vie une longue et belle
vie
ouais bah j'espère que je vais jamais
mourir tu vois j'espère que je vais
rester vivant lourd tant les stores
appelle le conseil et dealer que je
serai présent à l'examen
edgar de prendre de quoi les payer la
chambre
la cassure 7 avec plein de kaka parce
qu'il a chié dessus tellement il aura
peur
passez moi je conseille les fantômes
s'il vous plaît
battez lattois mais chez stagiaires des
conseils maintenant alors ernest des
feuilles né le 23 septembre 1940 est
mort le 15 mars 1904 vous êtes sur le
point de passer votre diplôme d' esprit
frappeur et d'accéder au rang de
fantômes de style il vous prêt à passer
cet examen
ouais vous allez donc chassé votre
premier client de l'hôtel celui la
chambre 407
quel sera votre approche je sais ce qui
lui fait peur
ap
on vous y allez là je n'achete pas
pardon j'y arrive pas je peux pas le
faire quand on est quatrième échec ou
qui vient à l'instant d'être relégué au
rôle sous merde c'est quoi faire [ __ ]
souvent ça vient d'être montée sous ben
ali
non mais je peux vous voir à mais on
sait on prend juste fauteuil pour s'en
faire un ami ok désolé ya un an d'un
vraiment trop mal ici qu'est ce tu as à
apa non je pensais que ce terrain est de
retour à west
vous avez en plus c'est ce à quoi non
maintenant on n'a pas rompu on est
parlant d pas ensemble on est on n'est
pas gai c'est pas grave d'être pd1
ce qui est grave dans l'histoire a en
gros c'est baiser avec un mort ça c'est
chaud par contre on n'a pas baiser on en
parle on n'a jamais baisé déjà on n'est
pas ensemble on est parent homosexuel
je suis pas homosexuel gène boeuf
d'ailleurs c'est l'immeuble d'en face
donc l'argent car oui voilà web à la 403
gelé vu rentrer dans sa chambre avec un
autre mec qui te le dis en quoi un grand
et tu faisais quoi tu t'es en train de
les chasser
non il était trop mignon on chasse pas
les gens trop mignon ici je sais toi et
moi on va faire un plan sans mon on me
raconte jacques à dire que tu es ma
nouvelle meuf tu vois mais genre t'as bu
un truc qui te rend invisible du genre
de petits plombs à la merde là c'est pas
pour moi c'est vraiment un truc de m
faut que tu sois honnête c'est ça qui
marche en fait tu vas l'avoir tu la
regardes dans les yeux
tu lui dis je suis [ __ ] je sus j'aime ça
c'est comme ça c'est métro liszt je suis
pas [ __ ] on n'est pas pdl restée moi on
est juste des amis ça mais tu vois
airness pour nous ici c'est le petit
frère alors qu'en fait c'est le plus
vieux et jamais il aura abandonné son
diplôme pour personne quoi il a
abandonné
donc fait pas ton gros [ __ ] va lui dire
tu l'aimais d'accord si ça peut te
rassurer le gars qui avait 403 il a un
tout petit zizi
alors que tient le liban voix
il
route car je les aurais vraiment désolé
bienvenue
il
donc tu as le droit de sortir de l'hôtel
comme ça que je suis enfant tôt ou tard
je suis vraiment désolée pour ce que je
te dis je le pensais pas et justement je
pense que tu as un rebond fantômes et
avait raison sur clara le laisser partir
je tenais à m'excuser c'est un peu long
à expliquer mais j'ai pas de
superpouvoirs
si j'étais menti pendant si longtemps
c'est parce que j'avais peur de perdre
tu nous expliques tu fais des trucs de
ouf pour te garder quoi je tiens à
m'excuser de ça ça lui attend félix
comment tu as fait pour
faire léviter mon lit a pas ce que je
peux voir le monde salue donc c'est
vraiment fini fini
tous
et apparemment gustave il un petit é moi
je suis je vais toucher
et j'ai bien réfléchi je vais partir de
l'hôtel en criant marage ça tu pourras
dire à tout le monde que tu m'as fait
peur c'est gentil mais c'est trop tard
ils ont annulé mon examen coup je suis
relégué au rang de souche ou merde ça
rend permanent donc même c'est arrivé à
chasser quelqu'un tu resterais une sous
merde
ouais donc en gros il faudrait que tu
fasses quelque chose de vraiment mais
alors vraiment vraiment très très gros
c'est ça ouais
parce que jenny près
ouais
oh mon dieu oh mon dieu elle est témoin
le télé haute et y apporte aux produits
bon ne vous inquiétez pas tout le monde
ce jeune qu'on fait une caméra cachée
pour internet
oh oh mon dieu mec mais qu'est ce qui
m'arrive comme toujours ils ont des
câbles c'est pour internet je vous ai
dit ok kobe ne paniquez pas ne leur
donnez pas cette satisfaction il veut
juste faire le buzz pour ces messieurs
il faut pour faire peur fin des trucs
assez cora wood tout ce qui m'arrive mon
dieu oh non non je voulais pas me suis
content non pas dans les faits
à
on est d'accord qu'on en parle jamais de
ça on dira que ce parti dès que tu me
tirait les pieds way for verra
non à part
écoute je faire de toi à ton pote tout
conseil appelé ils ont fait de toi de
quoi toi ton avantage chantôme de quoi
fantôme de style de style et avec du
avec du style fantôme de style moi je
suis un fantôme de style ernest fantôme
de style
monsieur bonjour j'ai réglé à ma chambre
sur play ouais très bien ça fait donc
cinq nuits ça va bien mal au cul un nom
n'en parle ans a déjà été payé 1 / merci
comment ça merci non pas toi toi toi ta
gueule
et
poignée de main d'homme
plus tard la voilà
chuck nbc
c'est des mecs qui sont un câlin sais
pas